it takes time to learn how to fly one of
these
an raf typhoon fighter jet
this one's used at air shows
the rest of the fleet is all about air
power against threats
the new f-35 also crucial
but leaked documents seen by sky news
revealed britain's ability to train fast
jet pilots to fly these aircraft is
under huge strain
a measly 11 recruits will learn to
operate them this year despite capacity
for almost four times that number
the reasons are complex
one of the files describes emerging
issues with the key hawk training jet
more than halving the length of time its
engine will work
the document says the impact on the
fastjet pathway will result in hold
lengths for pilots increasing to around
12 months for the next year for some
there's also concern about highly
qualified pilots choosing to quit the
raf for better paid jobs in the defence
industry rather than staying on to
operate jets and instruct recruits
the draw is so great from such a small
pool we're approaching a critical mass
point
the problems have a ripple effect all
the way back to here raf cranwell in
lincolnshire home to the officer
training college
right now dozens of graduates are
effectively flying desks rather than
warplanes as they wait for slots to open
up on the next stage of their training
some have been in this holding pattern
for so long they're having to take
refresher courses to relearn what
they've already been taught the
situation is hugely demoralizing for
individual pilots let alone what it's
doing to the ability of the air force to
fight in a crisis
a couple of hours drive away lies a
disused air base where fast jet recruits
once trained
linton on ooze was closed as part of raf
efforts to cut spending and streamline
training which has been plagued by
problems for years
a lot of it's been contracted out now
and does deliver what the raf has
requested
but this former officer says it's only
the bare minimum to keep costs low
someone's got to take a step back and
therefore set down what the real
strategic aims of the military flying
training system are and completely
reorganize it to have the flexibility in
the resilience to deliver what what you
need is an output because yes it's in a
crisis at the moment
an raf spokesperson said whilst we
acknowledge there are challenges with
the training pipeline we're working
across defence with industry and our
international partners to improve the
training experience and results for our
personnel
it's not just fast yet pilots left in a
holding pattern
other parts of the air force also have
trainees waiting for liftoff
debrahim sky news